الرئيس الامريكيه السابق دونالد ترامب
حوصره اكثر من مره بقضايا هددت موقعه
السياسي لكنه تلمس طريق الخروج متسلحا
باستراتيجيه غير منسقه لكنها ناسبت شخص
ترامب طبعا صحيفه
اوضحت بان ترامب نجا بصعوبه من اجراءات
عزل وتحقيقات واستفسارات الكونجرس معلله
ذلك بتكتيك ذكي تبعه الرئيس السابق ويشمل
تشويه سمعه المدعين العامين والمماطله
بالاجراءات والسماله القاعده الجمهوريه
وبالطبع هنا
الاتهامات جمله وتفصيلا يعتمد ترامب
مشاهدينا على فريق من المحامين
والمستشارين ليسوا على اتصال يذكر بل يشجع
على الاقتتال الداخلي بينهم وهو ما وصف
بالانتحار قانونيا اي فريق واحد بمسارات
متباينه
التقدم التحقيقات الجنائيه على عده جبهات
لفتت الصحيفه الامريكيه الى ان ترامب
يستخدم تكتيكات التشتيت المالوفه لمواجهه
فصل قانوني محتمل اكثر خطوره كما نشاهدون
فتره الذي بدا حملته الرئاسيه الثالثه قد
يواجه لائحه اتهام بدايه هذا الاسبوع على
خلفيه تحقيق فتاهه فتحه المدعي العام في
منهات بقضيه شراء صمت ممثله اباحيه كما
يواجه ترامب ايضا قضيتين منفصلتين احداهما
مرتبطه بجهوده لالغاء انتخابات عام 2020
في جورجيا تحديدا واخرى كما هو معلوم على
علاقه بالاحتيال
[موسيقى]